how does someone build then a network a
following online and you know that's
where it's almost a catch-22 to my
question so which comes first the
followers or the project seems like you
need those followers in place before you
show them the project but is there a
clean way to do it I have no answer for
that and I honestly don't know how we
build ours I mean I think was this again
work work work
yes you know being there communicating
telling things you know even something
away I think you know there are very
smart people doing that like I said Cody
or Ted hope they are even you know it's
very valuable what they say and normally
people would charge for that for the old
I advise to give it away for free and
then they say okay you know what I also
have a seminar and a workshop and a book
and you can learn something else but you
know all that was for free and it's
amazing that's how you build a community
and I think you know in a way that was
what happened to that we were really
open and really transparent and um we
gave away a lot of things how we were
making a film
what were the budget what was you know
everything how we made it it was useful
for people to know about but I don't
know we we build a community out of the
project but that's difficult again if
you can build 21st though that's better
but it doesn't mean it's gonna be
success I mean you can see this film of
the guy of no film school which it was a
success but you know he had like
thousand literally thousands of users
and it was it wasn't that big for all
the people he had behind so it depends
what kind of community you you built for
example our community is not that thick
I mean we have 6,000 followers in
Twitter and 60,000 in Facebook which is
a pretty small number for how the how
big the project has been I mean we've
been in every media in Spain in many
universities case studied in film and
business schools around the world and
it's just 6,000 people I've seen short
films with more fans than than we do
again that's because we
we did I mean we weren't harassing
people in line which is something easy
to do it's like you know follow me back
I will follow you for me back or or
whatever we just you know we just were
honest and transparent and that's why
the community is not huge but it's
really committed but I think more
important you know with only 6,000
people following us we were able to rise
a hundred thirty thousand in three days
out of that people because they were
committed and I even though they were
not a lot they were really committed
with the film so I think it's more
important to to have quality than
quantity
you